[Music]
[Applause]
he's booger McFarlane two-time Super
Bowl champ works for the mothership
covering the NFL and college football
give me the storyline that you're
interested in with hard knocks and the
Jets debuting tonight
just to see how much they're going to
show us DP uh I I think we're all
fascinated with the fact that Aaron
Rodgers is in New York the expectations
the defense if they could just get some
offense now he comes in
um I I think Aaron Rodgers is one of the
people in the National Football League
that's very intriguing because he thinks
differently than most people do and so I
think everyone is wondering are we going
to get a sneak peek under the hood at
the process that makes him go or are we
going to get any insightful things uh
from his perspective I think you know
everybody kind of knows sauce Gardener
and he's flashy and the defense and
Robert Sala and kind of the makeup but I
think Aaron Rodgers is the reason that
everybody's going to tune in to see if
they get a sneak peek at what makes this
guy go because the little that we've
gotten on Pat McAfee
um on their Tuesday interview I think
has us all very very uh Curious just to
know more
compare training camp for a veteran to a
rookie
um
you know that
that's one way to look at it I think
I'll break it down even further uh
training camp for a a veteran you know
what to expect you understand
uh what your role is usually coming into
Camp because a veteran player has kind
of already established you know the
rookie especially the rookie first
rounder uh has some of those same
sentiments but you don't really know
because you're trying to figure out
what's going to be my role uh
everybody's going to be looking at me
because you're a new player so even when
even when you're doing a rep everybody's
gonna be paying attention to the rookie
or the new guy just to see what they can
do because football is a collision sport
man it's played with pads on like all
the stuff we've done up until now has
been cool to run around in shorts and
look good and post Instagram and Tick
Tock videos but when the past go on
there's a legitimate feeling that you
could get your head knocked off and
that's when the game of football is
played so for a a veteran it's it's kind
of re-establishing who you are for a
rookie you got to let everyone know
where you come from and then to the
point that I was making to go a little
further training camp now is so
different than it was when I when I
played so my first training camp I held
out for two days and the very first day
I got there we were in full pads it was
four pads in the morning four pads in
the afternoon
well here's the deal DP now they got
this thing they called an acclimation
period I'm not sure what the hell it
means because it's going to be hot
regardless but you got to acclimate to
the Heat and acclimate the football the
same thing we've been playing for 15
years so it's so much easier now like
these guys can't go full pads back to
back they can't go full pads the first
five or six days uh it's really not
training camp it's more of a kind of get
together let's hang out for a couple of
weeks and and we're going to practice
once every other day and try to get this
thing figured out so it's it's so much
different between rookie and and Veteran
and it's also so much different between
now and then
was it ever personal with you with a
quarterback that you didn't like
uh no like it was more personal with me
with the guy that I went against across
from it like I used to have to line up
against guards and and like when your
defensive tackle going against an
offensive lineman you're really never
going to get a lot of one-on-one blocks
so it's always going to be double teams
and it used to bother me I'm like so
these dudes are professional they get
paid a lot of money but they can't
individually block me one-on-one every
single play and so like that that really
used to tick me off just the inherent
nature of the position I played and how
the offensive lineman would block us
would really kind of rub me the wrong
way but quarterback's doing their job
man like I didn't like any of them
um especially the ones that got rid of
the ball quick Brady Manning those guys
that didn't hold a football you love
going against a guy that was a bomb a
guy who held a football because you knew
it was going to be a good day for you
but overall like quarterbacks are who
they are but but who's the lineman you
you really personally hated
Uh Kevin Gogan was one
um Larry Allen was another one uh but
were they cheap shot artists like what
what would make you hate that guy that
it wasn't just it was it became personal
well it was personal because of the
position as I stated uh Gogan was a
cheap shot guy like yeah I think it's
been really uh documented some of the
chief shops that he took and some of the
dirty play that he had
um you know Todd Stussy was another guy
guys I just got under your skin like
there's there's this thing in the NFL
let's talk about playing until the echo
of the whistle well some offensive
lineman would do that and and they would
give you a little nudge a little cheap
shot Hey listen big guy and you had
three and a half seconds to block him
and you couldn't do it so now after the
play you want to give me a little nudge
like and and they do it just to get
under your skin so
um but yeah I don't like any of them man
just because I mean these dudes are big
they're usually bad built and they
always need help to do their job
talking to Booger McFarland two-time
Super Bowl champ and uh analyst for ESPN
NFL and college football uh you had uh
Jamar Chase say if Joe Burrows not a
hundred percent he wouldn't have a
problem with him maybe sitting out the
first five games of the regular season I
know that they don't have great
competition in four of those five games
but you're still playing the Browns and
Ravens to start off your season uh your
thoughts on trying to protect Joe burrow
for as long as you can
well I completely agree because with the
Joe Borough they can win the Super bowl
without him they're just the middle of
the pack team and so uh uh fortunately
time you know right now they had a gift
of time it's what August the 8th uh they
don't plug meaningful game for over a
month I I wouldn't be surprised if we
don't see Joe burrow on the practice
field until Wednesday of game week uh he
doesn't need to be out there yeah he
might be a little rusted but I'd rather
have Joe burrow Rusty for game one than
to come back too early and re-injure
that and now he starts missing uh a
significant part of the Season uh even
if he's got to miss the first game or
two I'm still fine with that like it's a
17 Game season over the course of 18
weeks uh I think his sentiment that I
don't want to see Gerald Joe burrow back
until he is as healthy as possible is
one that a lot of people in that
organization share
Dalvin cook still out outside looking in
Zeke Elliott on the outside looking in
um is this an anomaly or do you think
this is going to be a growing Trend in
the off season in years to come
yeah I think the running back position
as we talked about has been the value
um I I think that you're going to see uh
a lot of the Veteran running backs that
want a lot of money they're going to
have to kind of wait until some team
kind of bites like it's supply and
demand so if I got a guy that I drafted
in the third or fourth round that I feel
can do the same job or just as as good a
job as a guy like Gavin cook or Ezekiel
really why am I going to go out and pay
you know seven eight million for either
one of those guys and so I think for
Dalvin cook and Ezekiel Elliott they're
both going to be on opening day rosters
I think they're both going to play a
vital role uh with some team I think
Dalvin cook has more juice left in the
tank four straight seasons over a
thousand yards he's only 27 years old
think about that DP think about if
somebody told you at 27 you were no good
like at 27 I wasn't even stretching I I
just touching my toes and got and and
went to work and now at 27 they're
saying that these guys are kind of
washed up so uh it's a a very very
difficult predicament to be in I do
think Dalvin cook is going to be uh a
starter at some point in this league
he's just got too much juice left in the
tank but I kind of feel for Zeke though
because if Zeke doesn't go to maybe
Dallas I know New England has kind of uh
brought him in like where does Zeke go
and how much money is he going to have
to settle for at some point they're
gonna have to swallow their pride uh
Zeke I think and say okay I'm gonna play
for a one-year deal for I don't know two
or three million bucks which is a far
cry from what Jerry paid him in Dallas
how much do you think you would earn now
if you were picking LSU
uh wow uh a lot of money because well
what's the going rate for a defensive
tackle
well I I I think the going rate for a
five-star defense tackle is probably I
don't know probably probably a million
bucks a year at least okay I mean think
about that think about that DP
I was I was a three four star guy coming
out of Louisiana and my first two years
at LSU there were several several
weekends where I had five bucks to my
name the training table wasn't open and
I was eating ramen noodles and Chinese
food all weekend now these guys got a
million dollars in the bank uh they're
the toast of the town and they're
getting that in high school not in
college like these guys are being paid
in high school once they commit to shut
down their recruiting until Signing Day
and then once you get to the school of
your choice you're getting paid even
more money so uh I was born just a
little bit too early uh but I don't envy
these guys because more money comes more
problems and when I got to the NFL at 21
I didn't really understand that
statement but I quickly learned that the
more money I got the more headaches came
so I can only imagine what these kids at
17 are dealing with when they got a
million bucks in the bank they're 17
years old and they got to go to school
oh oh by the way you're still 17 and
you're a kid but now you got to deal
with the issues that 21 year old adults
have to deal with I don't envy that at
all
who's kind of better Louisiana accent
you or Brian Kelly
uh well I'm a Country Boy from Louisiana
so my accent is really kind of uh not
really Southern and not really Cajun so
I could really teach BK a little bit of
uh about how to get it a little better
although here's what I will say I will
give him credit for trying I will give
him credit also for acknowledging that
it was terrible uh but all jokes aside
he's been exactly what LSU has needed
which is an adult in the room somebody
that could be a CEO type of a major
Powerhouse program and we'll see what he
does with expectations 10 wins year one
we'll see what he does in year two with
the preseason ranking of number five but
he didn't have to give an accent you
don't have to if I if I go down to
Louisiana I don't all of a sudden you
know start talking and we haven't even
won all of our games yes but I mean he
he really sound like a Louisiana guy
from 1950 uh you know
putting on the smokers Jackie grabbing a
cigar sitting on the front porch so if
if you really wanted to do it he should
have picked up a bowl of crawfish
etouffee and just kind of start uh using
that French Cajun cuisine
great to talk to you booger hope you're
doing well hope the golf game is good
DP I'm doing great man the golf game is
excellent
um I'm enjoying life ready for football
season to start man and and this year
here's one promise I can make you okay I
will make a meat Friday because we've
been talking about this for several
years I will make a meat Friday this
year you let me know what you want you
let me know what you want and then we'll
cook it on the Traeger grill
I'm looking forward to sausage beef
brisket okay and maybe just a little bit
of uh maybe just a little bit of tri-tip
okay
we can do that for you just give me give
me advance notice here like a day or so
and then we'll uh we'll cook it up
will do buddy all right thank you booger
yes I bet he can get after it too yeah I
would think so that's a hell of a day
right there that that's a message yeah